[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
defense attorneys for convicted wife
killer scott peterson accuse a juror of
not disclosing she was a crying victim
while pregnant could this be grounds for
a new trial the evidence used against
the colorado father accused of murdering
his son
see key blood and forensics in the mark
redwine trial breaking down derek
chovin's sentence for the murder of
george floyd
how judge peter cahill reached 22 and a
half years and what's next for the
former police officer
robert durst fires back at prosecutors i
am not seeking
sympathy from the truth the head of the
billion dollar real estate company durst
organization
takes the stand against his own brother
accused of murder
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
scott peterson's lawyers filed new court
documents claiming a juror lied
about being the victim of a crime while
she was pregnant angina labia is here
with how this could result
in a new trial for one of america's most
well-known inmates
brian juror rachelle niece was nicknamed
strawberry shortcake during that month's
long trial peterson's lawyers say niece
lied about being a victim of a crime
when she filled out her juror
questionnaire now niece was juror number
seven
in the trial that led to peterson's
conviction for the murder of his wife
lacey
and their unborn son in 2004. well court
documents reveal
that niece had been beaten by her
boyfriend in 2001.
prosecutors have said in prior court
filings that niece misinterpreted the
questions on the questionnaire
niece had also sought and obtained a
restraining order against her
boyfriend's ex
fearing some sort of harassment after
that woman slashed her boyfriend's tires
niece also wrote several letters to
peterson in prison in 2005 and 2006
in which she questioned him about lacey
and connor's deaths
to try to get him to confess
so we caught a number of stealth jurors
but we did not catch miss niece
and you know it's it ruins the whole
process
and not just for scott peterson but for
all the feminists when you have
a preconceived notion about guilt or
innocence
there's nothing wrong with that that's
fine you know you're welcome to your
opinion
but you shouldn't get off the live and
get on the jury
to hurt that person
now the judge in the case has said she
will make a decision soon about whether
she's going to have an evidentiary
hearing on this juror issue
if that happened rachelle niece would be
called to testify and subjected to
questioning by both sides now peterson
could will be back in court in
august and the judge has also said she
will make a decision
this year about whether or not peterson
gets a new
trial brian thanks angenet joining us
today is defense attorney suanne
robinson
and terry austin so looking at the
actions of this juror strawberry
shortcake as she's been called
how big of a deal is her non-disclosure
in terms of getting an impartial jury
i think the issue is her actually if she
misrepresented purposefully then
obviously she's lying and that's really
what the big deal is
i personally don't think that her having
that experience
necessarily makes her unable to be
impartial
i think the issue and the appellate
issue is going to be
if if she's lying if she lied if she
didn't answer
the if she purposefully was trying to be
a stealth juror
that's going to be a big deal on appeal
for scott peterson
yeah it makes sense because then if she
told the truth both sides would have
been able to use a peremptory challenge
or maybe ask for the questions
could have played out a little
differently terry what do you expect the
judge to decide uh
retrial or hearing well i think what she
should do is to have a hearing because
as suanne pointed out
the real question is whether or not this
juror was
lying and the judge specifically said if
the motion papers are strong enough
she's going to make a decision as to
whether or not there should be a retrial
but if they are not strong enough she is
going to have an evidentiary hearing
and the hearing would obviously include
this juror so
under oath she would have to answer
questions as to
what she said during the war dear and if
in fact
she was lying then i do think that might
be a grounds for appeal because
everyone obviously is entitled to a fair
and impartial jury
it will definitely be an interesting
hearing if that does happen
and janet isn't scott peterson also
facing a re-sentencing
yeah he definitely is brian this is an
interesting case because we have these
kind of two separate issues the
re-sentencing since the california
supreme court
sent the case back and said there were
errors and there needed to be a
re-sentencing the prosecution said they
will not pursue the death penalty this
time around
so it will automatically be life without
parole however peterson's lawyer pat
harris is saying well but we have this
other issue about the durham misconduct
so there may be a whole new trial so
there's this whole thing about does he
get a new trial do we resentence him to
life without parole when there's
the possibility that he gets a new trial
so there's a lot going on with the case
yeah a lot of moving pieces we'll see
how those all fit in of course we gotta
wait to see what this whole
jury question is maybe that's what the
judge is waiting for decide that before
deciding the sentencing
thank you all now to other top legal
news
marilyn manson has reportedly reached an
agreement for him to surrender to police
in an assault case the provocative
musician is known for his controversial
stage personality
police in new hampshire accused manson
of committing assault against a
videographer in august 2019.
in a statement to law and crime the
guilford police chief says manson plans
to surrender in los angeles
manson also faces multiple sexual
assault allegations
including those by his former fiance
evan rachel wood
and actress asme blanco britney spears
has reportedly escaped to hawaii days
after speaking out in court regarding
her conservatorship
in a passionate statement the pop singer
requested an end to the lengthy
conservatorship
under which her father controls many
aspects of her life
including finances not long after her
plea spears were spotted walking the
beaches of maui with her boyfriend
now to florida where the man accused of
shooting a police officer in the head
was arrested in georgia where the
officers own handcuffs
the officer was investigating a
suspicious vehicle when the driver
29-year-old o'thal wallace allegedly
shot the officer and took off
wallace was found after a 56-hour
manhunt hiding in a tree house
east of atlanta at around 2 30 a.m
saturday morning
police say they also found an array of
firearms and ammunition
the daytona beach police chief shared
pictures of the arrest
showing wallace in the injured officer's
handcuffs and expressing his excitement
of catching the suspect
still ahead on law and crime daily derek
show been sentenced to 22 and a half
years in prison
but what's next but first we take a
black light to the trial of mark redwine
the prosecutor illuminates evidence in
the murder of a 13 year old boy
next
[Music]
welcome back the jury in mark redwine's
trial hears about blood
and dna found in the colorado man's home
law and crimes angel levy is back with a
testimony
several locations in mark redwine's
living room and it will be up to the
jury to decide
what that dna means as it relates to
dylan redwine's death
a crime scene investigator examined mark
redwine's home in 2012
using luminol and a black light several
areas lit up
showing possible blood samples were sent
to a dna analyst
loveseat couch cushion from room b that
were
positive for the presumptive presence of
blood in the laboratory
there were swabs that were collected
from the floor under the rug
near the coffee table of room b rebecca
strut
tested the areas that were swabbed from
the loveseat coffee table and floor
under a rug in mark redwine's home
the dna profile from the swabs from the
loveseat of the
south cushion of room b item 2.1
matches the dna profile developed from
dylan redwine
but another area had a mixture of dna
the dna profile that was developed from
the swabs from the floor under the
rug fresh coffee table of room b
indicates a mixture cory redwine and
dylan redwine cannot be excluded as
potential contributors to this mixture
mark redwine's attorney seized on the
fact that a mixture of dna was found
to cast doubt on what the dna in mark
redwine's home
could mean one thing dna cannot tell you
is who contributed contributed
the blood to that mixture correct that
is correct
meaning your analysis can't say corey
definitely contributed the blood
to this material correct that is correct
prosecutors tried to eliminate any doubt
that dylan's blood was found in that
living room
there were multiple locations in that
room where they tested presumptive
positive for blood
and the prosecutor also asked the dna
analyst
whether or not dylan's blood was found
in several locations in that living room
and she said it was
brian let's bring back defense attorney
suanne robinson and terry austin
terry where do you think the defense was
going with their argument of mixture of
blood and
do you think it was successful you know
brian
the job of the defense attorney is as
you know to raise some reasonable doubt
and that's exactly what he was trying to
do
but the dna expert was pretty definitive
here she said without a doubt she
confirmed that
multiple locations tested positive
for presumption that it was dylan's
blood so the fact that another area
might have a mixture of
cory's broth and his blood doesn't
really mean
as much because they are siblings and
hopefully the jury will understand
that most of the blood in that room was
dylan's blood and that does
indicate that there was some sort of
violence seen at that
location now swan i'm guessing that's
what the prosecution's going to try to
say
blood all over the living room but how
do you think the prosecution can piece
that together in the summation
to kind of paint a picture for the jury
i think the prosecution has a
a little bit of an obstacle and the fact
that obviously the mixture creates a
reasonable doubt as terry pointed out
i think it's their job to almost
reconstruct
the crime scene for the jury to the
extent they can based on the evidence
to kind of give them an idea like you
said about
the fact that it must have been a
violent scene for
the decedent's blood to be splattered
different places
and possibly if the evidence permits
they could say that there was an attempt
to clean up which is why it's not pooled
in
areas because sometimes with luminol you
can tell
if there was a removal in some areas so
i think it's going to be up to the
prosecution to really dig
in with their expert witness's testimony
and take out the pieces
um so that in summation they can put
together
the actual altercation that they're
alleging led to the death
makes sense to me anjanet the dna
analyst was also asked about what might
happen
if someone was punched in the face or
hit by the back of the skull right
yeah she was asked that by the
prosecutor and whether or not that would
leave a large amount of blood on the
fist of the person who
punched the other person and she said
not necessarily
so and she was also asked whether or not
you know
she gets large quantities pounds of dna
into the crime lab to analyze and she
said no
she doesn't usually the samples are very
small very small just picograms as they
call them and measuring blood and dna
thank you all coming up on law and crime
daily robert durst stands up for himself
pleading with a judge for help plus a
cryptic message by derek sherman as he
is sentenced for the murder of george
floyd
what he said and didn't next
[Music]
welcome back we're now learning more
about a judge's decision sentencing
former minneapolis police officer
derek shoving for the murder of george
floyd
judge peter cahill sentenced chauvin to
22 and a half years in prison
the time is based on the top charge
chauvin was convicted of second-degree
unintentional murder
judge cahill authored a 26-page
sentencing order
writing in it that he departed from the
state guidelines of a 12 and a half year
sentence
because he found two aggravating factors
that showed and abused his position of
trust and authority
and that he treated floyd with
particular cruelty
under minnesota guidelines shobhan will
serve two-thirds of his sentence
meaning he will be released from prison
in 15 years but
he's also facing federal civil rights
violation charges
chauvin is due back in federal court for
his arraignment in september
back with this is my guest suanne
robinson who's of counsel
for the benjamin crump law firm the firm
representing george floyd's family
so and with the federal charges coming
up i know a lot of focus is
what's going to happen with these
federal charges and how are they going
to interact
so to speak with the state charges do
you think he could get more time
with the federal government and could
that time run consecutively but
concurrent what do you think
well it's important brian as you pointed
out in the package
that these are going to be civil rights
violations he's not being tried directly
for the murder and what generally and
typically happens is
you know he's going to be serving his 15
years
in state court out of his 22.5
year sentence and then he would be if he
was convicted on these federal charges
he would then be moved to a federal
jail to serve his time he probably his
trial
probably won't even take place till next
year and that will he'll obviously be
moved from
state jail to federal custody in order
to sit through his trial
but once he's convicted if he's
convicted on federal charges
after his state sentence is over then he
will serve in a federal jail
now question for you suanne when i was
there in minneapolis when he was being
sentenced he gave almost like a very
cryptic
message to the family very short
condolence but said that
maybe in the short future they'll get
something to give them a peace of mind
uh what did you make of that message did
it maybe
shoot off any bells in your ears as to
what he might be thinking about
um i i you know to me i think that he
his statement didn't give
the remorse that you're looking for at
that stage
after conviction's already been done
after there's a video
showing what occurred you know the
family is looking for remorse they're
not really looking for
cryptic statements or you know i'll get
back with you later
and that's kind of how his statement
read to me
it was kind of like a teaser like more
to come
which at this point the family's already
been through so much
that it i don't think it worked in his
favor
i get it he has federal charges pending
they're different charges
and he may be assessing and weighing in
his mind if something that he says that
sentencing
is going to affect him in his federal
case i get it
but i think that if you're going to
bother to stand up there and talk to the
family
that you should do it from the heart and
and um show remorse
absolutely i know a lot of people had
similar criticism about his mother's
impact statement
making no reference to the floyd family
and only talking about her favorite son
thank you suanne when we come back durst
has had enough
and breaks his silence in the middle of
court his words to the judge and
prosecutor
and douglas durst takes the stand the
testimony you don't want to miss
ahead
welcome back testimony is resuming in
the robert durst trial but
before the jury was brought in the real
estate heir made his voice heard
robert durst is charged with murdering
his best friend susan berman
in december 2000. investigators say
durst killed berman
because she was a witness to the still
unsolved 1982 disappearance
of durr's first wife kathy defense
attorneys for durst says he's innocent
and is suffering from failing health
including bladder cancer
prosecutor john lewin has accused durst
of exaggerating his condition
to gain sympathy from the jury he's also
personally helped durst change his
catheter bag
during breaks in court durr says he
wants his catheter
taken out the rule
is incorrect i am not seeking sympathy
from the truth
my head is shaved this is the only kind
of haircut that i'm able to get
in the jab in terms of this whole thing
about my seeking sympathy and trying to
harm myself
with my catheter bag i have been doing
everything possible
to get the juror to get the doctors at
ctc
to remove the bag i don't want to have
the catheter
at all terry i think for durst that's a
bit of an outburst for him considering
how much strength or lack there he has
what did you think about him speaking
out in court and what he said to the
court
you know what brian this is the most
bizarre trial i have
ever seen the fact that he just stood up
and said can i say something and then
he's trying to explain
that he's not faking anything and it was
just to really confront what lewin has
been saying all along
very interesting i don't think it's
going to make that big a difference at
all in this trial and of course this was
before the jury was brought in
and we also know that his brother took
the stand any inclination as to what you
heard from the brother that may have
helped the prosecution or maybe even
help the defense
but you know what first before we get
there now to testimony the trial
robert durst's brother douglas took the
stand and says he was aware
that kathy durst was trying to file for
divorce he denied rumors that he was
involved with cathy's disappearance
do you have any knowledge of of what
happened to
kathy i have no knowledge no
did you have anything to do with her
disappearance absolutely not
do you have any knowledge that your
father had anything to do with her
disappearance
absolutely not did you have anything to
do with
covering up whatever mr durst might have
done to her
i find that a very insulting question
but no i did not
and are you aware if your father had any
involvement in allegedly covering up
i have no knowledge of it i also find
that insulting
the real estate heirs brother went on to
say that he feared the defendant
testifying about
death threats he received
were you afraid of your brother yes i
was because my brother when he gets
angry he gets
extremely angry has your brother
indicated how he feels about you to this
day
yes and what are those feelings he'd
like to murder me
and are you aware of your brother in
fact making calls from pennsylvania
discussing that very subject i am aware
of that
did you take those and this is a yes or
no question do you take
those threats seriously yes i did
all right terry let's get right into
douglas uh uh durs hero lewin starting
his
death by a thousand questions technique
um how was uh
doug durst testimony in terms of tying
up all the loose ends for lewin
you know what brian you hit it right on
the head loon asked a million questions
he started from the beginning and went
to the end and i think douglas sturs did
a fantastic job
establishing everything lewin needed to
have
established those main points include
the fact that
the brothers did not like durst they all
feared him they thought that robert
durst was going to
kill them and that is the most strangest
testimony to hear from a brother
and douglas durst also said he wasn't
even
invited to his brother's wedding and
that you know they uh chose
him over bob to run the company and that
was bad
blood between them and that no one
really liked bob
and that he was you know lying about the
father he said the father was
strict and overbearing when in fact
they'll confirm
that the father was a wonderful father
and he lied about
the mother all along apparently bob
durst has been saying
that he was made to watch his mother
fall off the roof and in fact that's not
true so
i think that douglas durst overall was
an excellent witness
the one was able to establish everything
yeah this seems more like
a story of cain and abel rather than
modern-day brothers but
thank you for joining us here on law on
crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you